the closer the category itself you know
where green is relevant such as a Prius
car or marketing solar technology for
people to use in their home where it
might supply electricity or heated water
there you can make a very direct
connection between the category and the
purchase and how the company's is
behaving and its characteristics in
driving a green movement now a little
bit further afield we see that companies
that are doing the job of managing
resources and talking about it general
electric for instance with their
ecomagination campaign was one of the
first to talk about this across their
portfolio of offerings you it's a little
bit more difficult to make the direct
connection to what I bought in green but
I would point out to the work that's
been done in cradle to cradle not cradle
to grave but the notion that i can
design something that at end of life can
actually be reused the components is now
driving awareness to a new level of not
just sustainability but thrive ability
right something that is is more
important than than simply getting by
but cradle to cradle is about being able
to do something that's positive that has
momentum in the future so when I think
about green I think about green in terms
of being you know thriving
no I don't think so if you look broadly
at what is a brand you know one of the
first organizations that had a structure
that we might consider similar to a
contemporary company it's the Catholic
Church Catholic Church has been around
for a long time right you can talk about
you know what kind of a brand is that
but it's it's a fairly salient
persistent organization in terms of
commercial activity there are department
stores such as daimaru in Japan that are
almost thousand years old all right and
we wouldn't think of them in
contemporary terms as brands that the
change you know the oldest brand
probably in your in your kitchen is king
come in soy sauce the symbol of the
turtle right that's highly stylized goes
back to the mogy family making soy sauce
right all the way back into the things
1200 and so that's a very old brand been
very pervasive and persistent in
delivering quality that was appropriate
in Japan and is still appropriate in
your kitchen today
I think it's extremely important for
companies to engage but I want to remind
people that online is not the only way
to do it or if you have known someone
personally in person I think the quality
of online engagement is so much stronger
when I've had a face-to-face meeting or
I've known you for a while the you know
the pure online world is relatively flat
without the personal engagement and
face-to-face relationships so what I
want to remind companies is that as you
make these investments online is it's a
miracle what we can do today in terms of
connecting with others but it's just
that much stronger and the emotional
ties really come from the face-to-face
personal engagement that we have with
others and so we need to blend both the
physical world and the virtual world
together to have the most powerful